so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Jesus hate zombies and
while I was only able to get my hands on
the first few comics what I'm hoping is
that at the end of this you'll have had
a good time as well as have your
interest piqued and what this series has
to offer
so Jesus hate zombies was written by
Stephen Lindsey in 2007 released under
alternate comics a small independent
publisher for fledgling creators and
it's composed of a series of miniature
three to four page issues as the story
opens the basis behind the situation
establishes that the earth has been
ravaged by a zombie plague of unknown
origin however amidst the Walking Dead
lies a small Church in a large city
which houses a handful of survivors and
so from here the story jumps to heaven
with Jesus and God hanging out in a spa
while smoking a cigar and enjoying the
steam and God informs Jesus that because
of the zombie outbreak he's being sent
back to earth and were to wipe the slate
clean and keep the survivors alive
because he's been isolated to heaven for
so long without the opportunity to crack
some skulls
Jesus jumps for joy at the idea of
returning to earth
however the catch is that because
Jesus's powers are tied directly to the
faith that people have in him and
because there are so few people left the
powers of Jesus will be virtually
non-existent and so jumping to earth
itself in a manner identical to
terminator Jesus breaks into a clothing
store in order to gather supplies and
protection for himself following this
and after providing himself with a means
to deal with the zombies Jesus leaves
the store with a Louisville Slugger and
begins the Lord's work by smashing the
head off of a zombie and taking them all
for a ride on a plane train now from
here we jump to an unknown amount of
time later after Jesus has been
travelling the country but finding each
church empty because Jesus is virtually
human without his powers he experiences
hunger where he travels to a local
Italian market that does not appear to
have been raided however once he enters
the market he discovers that the reason
why it's never been raided is because
the owner has remained there with a gun
attempting to reason with the shop owner
Jesus tells him who he is
but because the situation is so dire and
his faith in God has been abandoned the
shop owner basically tells Jesus to get
out before he shoots him in the face
continuing to try to rationalize with
the man by telling him that he was sit
there by God the owner begins to count
down from three and once he begins to
realize that the guy isn't messing
Jesus makes the decision to leave the
facility transitioning to Whispering
Pines rest home after having been on the
move for four days with no rest
Jesus decides to use it as a place to
catch some sleep in order to make his
next decisions with a clear head because
the building appears completely vacant
the initial idea is that the elderly who
had lived there died somewhere along the
line and their bodies were likely
disposed of
however after hearing music coming from
the dancing Hall Jesus enters where he
discovers that the elderly are all
zombies and are dancing to the sound of
music putting out a cigarette and
putting boots to asses Jesus uses a meat
cleaver on the deceased geriatrics and
puts him down for the count
after clearing the room Jesus comments
on how much fight the old people had in
them and goes as far as lamenting the
fact that back in his day living to 40
years was considered old and so as this
collection of comics comes to an end
Jesus takes the knife to the record
player destroying it in the process and
rejoicing at the fact that there's
finally some peace and quiet with that
being said I know this was a short video
guys but I can only get my hands on a
couple of comics but I love this story
was absolutely hilarious watching Jesus
travel around the world killing zombies
is amazing and I will catch you guys on
it peace